[Musique]
l'établissement public d'aménagement
Paris-Saclay génère un volume important
de Limonaire
issu des
opérations de terrassement suite au
travaux d'aménagement que l'on mène sur
l'ensemble des actes du Sud plateau
il était donc important de créer une
filière de revalorisation de ces de ces
terres
l'opération consiste à caractériser ces
terres donc en faisant des sondages pour
s'assurer que les terres ne sont pas
trop pollués chimiquement
ensuite on effectue un tri on enlève les
déchets tout ce qui peut être déchets
plastiques ou des déchets externes
apportés par des tiers une fois que le
tri effectué on met en stock nos terres
et on y ajoute du compost
issus des déchets verts et on termine
par la mise en place d'un couvert
végétal qui va créer des racines au sein
de ses stocks ce qui va permettre à la
biodiversité de ce de se développer et
d'aérer les terres et de la Transformer
non pas en limon mais en terre végétale
sur cette opération donc avec les stocks
que l'on voit derrière moi on a
revalorisé 50 000 m3 et on a un taux de
revalorisation de 95%. donc ce qui est
une amélioration assez conséquente
depuis la première opération de
remédiation que l'on avait mené sur la
ZAC de Polytechnique et de corbeille
en termes d'utilisation ces stocks de
terre d'ici 2 à 3 ans on aura à dispo de
la terre végétale que l'on pourra
utiliser pour nos aménagements sur
l'ensemble des espaces publics des trois
actes et également pourquoi pas
en proposer à des agriculteurs qui
voudraient l'utiliser en terre
agronomique donc pour l'agriculture on
sait que cela va subvenir aux besoins
dans un premier temps pour l'aménagement
de la ZAC de moulons de corbeille et de
Polytechnique mais avec un stock aussi
conséquent on arrivera aussi sûrement à
en laisser aux collectivités à qui on va
rétrocéder les espaces publics dans
quelques années
[Musique]